[Musique]
c'est le jour j pour myosotis dans moins
de deux heures
le taureau charolais monte aura pour la
première fois sur le grand ring du salon
de l'agriculture
pour séduire le jury le beau mâle a le
droit à une séance de remise en beauté
brossage des poils et blanchissement des
coraux
sarah charolaise qui contient les cordes
blanche puis décors sont blanches la
qualité de l'air pour frédéric et
guillaume c'est aussi le baptême du feu
c'est la première fois qu'il participe
au salon de l'agriculture mais loin de
leurs pâturages de saône et loire
les deux éleveurs ne sont pas très
rassurants les plus stressés on va dire
c'est laisser les éleveurs pouvoir entre
guillemets parce qu'on a toujours peur
qu'il arrive quelque chose aussi bien
un peu avec le grand public zurichois
tant qu'il sera pas retourner dans ces
pâturages du charolais 20 ans là on sera
on sera toujours en tension permanente
ce déplacement à paris c'est aussi un
sacrifice car au même moment des veaux
sont en train de naître chez frédéric
l'éleveur s'est fait remplacer par ses
voisins mais à 400 km de chez lui il
garde un oeil rivé sur sa ferme en train
de regarder les vaches qui est en train
de ne mettre pas pour l'instant ce
moment-là salaires des 25 m du coup
peuvent hélas depuis que cette partie là
il y en a eu trois
les ce matin
la version jeu peut-être pas fini c'est
nora tête encore soir en rentrant ce
soir qu'on va rentrer vers 11h puis on
est enfin 2 3 dans la nuit ça veut dire
qu'on va passer nuit blanche
guillaume lui aussi a dû se faire
remplacer pour lui comme pour frédéric
pas le temps de faire du tourisme dans
la capitale
les propriétaires de myosotis sont là
pour faire du business et rentrer dans
leurs frais l'hôtel
les placements
tout un ensemble ça revient cher quand
même à la fin ok des retombées derrière
le moment tant attendu est arrivé
myosotis va enfin se rendre sur le ring
le taureau de 1400 kg se fraie un chemin
au milieu de la foule
ce moment les bourguignons le savoure on
défile à paris pour un en-avant défile
pas sur l'acte de triomphe mais on n'est
pas loin quoi main sans oublier un petit
peu la ferme droit d'y aller une petite
heure c'est quand même un événement on
verra pas tous les jours quoi on l'a
tellement vous préparer il était chez
nous
c'est ce après quatre ans mais vous
rendez compte déjà un peu du volume
après 30 minutes de délibération les
résultats tombent
myosotis ne remportera pas le prix du
meilleur mâle leur producteur doit se
contenter d'une quatrième place avec un
très bon taureau dont premier
voilà ce qu'il en est qu'est ce qui va
se passer là maintenant vous rentrez bas
on va rentrer retourner dans
l'exploitation et du travail qui nous
attend
voilà pas un petit toit la tour eiffel
avant alors la droite oissel on viendra
quand payera pas de morale visiter la
tour eiffel voilà pour frédéric et
guillaume le salon de l'agriculture se
termine
les deux éleveurs repartent de paris
avec plusieurs contacts à la clé
myosotis lui restera ici encore quelques
jours